[Music]
foreign
[Music]
stash put on some vinyl records or disco
boots your choice and smell that lead in
the gasoline because we are heading back
to the 1970s the 70s were not only my
favorite decade to look back on but they
were a decade of the upheaval for the
genre transforming horror into a
legitimate vessel for awards recognition
and blockbusters
foreign
[Music]
of hammer Gothic horror had its last
gasp here with vampire circus giving way
to the Whodunnit sleeves of Italian
Diallo like deep red American realism
with Texas Chainsaw Massacre and
Grindhouse Last House on the Left
meanwhile Legends in the making made
their name off of horror Steven
Spielberg with duel Ridley Scott with
alien David Lynch with Eraserhead and
John Carpenter with Halloween just to
name a few
foreign
[Music]
now that you're all keyed up get down
for some Boogie Nights as we count down
the best scary movies that the 1970s
gave us
[Music]
number 10 Dawn of the Dead
as hordes of zombies swarm over the
United States the terrified populist
tries everything in their power to
escape the attack of the undead but
neither cities nor the countryside prove
safe in Pennsylvania radio station
employs Stephen and his girlfriend
Francine Escape in the station
helicopter accompanied by two Renegade
swap members Roger and Pete now the
group retreats to The Haven of an
enclosed shopping center to make what
could be Humanity's Last Stand starring
David emgy Ken fourie Galen Ross and
directed by George A Romero critics say
one of the most compelling and
entertaining zombie films ever Dawn of
the Dead perfectly Blends pure horror
and Gore with social commentary on
material Society
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
how many of you think you're already in
I don't know not too many
we'll get them easy
we'll get it all locked off then we're
going on a hunt
[Music]
number nine Invasion of the Body
Snatchers
this remake of the classic horror film
is set in San Francisco Matthew Bunnell
assumes that when a friend complains of
her husband's strange mood that it's a
marital issue however he begins to worry
as more people report similar
observations and his concern is
confirmed when writer Jack Belichick and
his wife discover a mutated corpse
besieged by an invisible enemy but now
must work quickly before the city is
consumed starring one of my favorite
actors of all time Donald Sutherland
Brooke Adams Leonard Nimoy and directed
by Philip Kaufman critics say employing
gritty camera work and evocative sound
effects Invasion of the Body Snatchers
is a powerful remake that expands upon
themes and ideas only lightly explored
in the original
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
number eight Suspiria
City travels to Germany to attend ballet
school when she arrives late on a stormy
night no one lets her in and she sees
Pat another student fleeing from the
school when Pat reaches her apartment
she is murdered and the next day Susie
is admitted to her new school but has a
difficult time settling in she hears
noises and often feels ill as more
people die and Susie uncovers the
terrifying secret history of the place
starring Jessica Harper Stefania Cassini
Joan Bennett and directed by Dario
Argento critics say the blood pours
freely in argento's classic Suspiria a
giallo horror as grandiose and glossy as
it is Gory
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number seven Carrie
in this chilling adaptation of Stephen
King's horror novel withdrawn
insensitive team Carrie White faces
taunting from classmates at school and
abused from her fanatically Pious Mother
at home when strange occurrences start
happening around Kerry she begins to
suspect that she has Supernatural Powers
invited to the prom by the empathetic
Tommy Ross Carrie tries to let her guard
down but things eventually take a dark
and violent turn starring [ __ ] Spacek
Piper Laurie William cat and directed by
Brian De Palma critics say Carrie is a
horrifying look at Supernatural Powers
High School cruelty and teen angst and
it brings us one of the most memorable
and disturbing prom scenes in history
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
number six Young Frankenstein
respected medical lecturer Dr Frederick
Frankenstein learns that he has
inherited his Infamous grandfather's
estate in Transylvania arriving at the
castle Dr Frankenstein soon begins to
recreate his grandfather's experiments
with the help of servants Igor Inga and
the Fearsome brow blucher after he
creates his own monster new
complications ensue with the arrival of
the doctor's fiancee Elizabeth starring
Gene Wilder Peter Boyle Cloris Leachman
and directed by Mel Brooks critics say
made with obvious affection for the
original Young Frankenstein is a
riotously silly spoof featuring a
fantastic performance by Gene Wilder
from that fateful day when stinking bits
of slime first crawled from the sea and
shouted to the cold Stars
I am man
our greatest dread has always been the
knowledge of our own mortality
but tonight
we shall hurl The Gauntlet of science
into the frightful face of death itself
[Music]
tonight
we shall Ascend into the heavens
the earthquake
and penetrate into the very warm of
impervious nature herself
[Music]
number five don't look now
still grieving over the accidental death
of their daughter Christine John and
Laura Baxter head to Venice Italy where
John's been commissioned to restore a
church there Laura meets two sisters who
claim to be in touch with the spirit of
the Baxter's daughter but John scoffs
until he himself catches a glimpse of
what looks like Christine running
through the streets of Venice starring
Julie Christie Donald Sutherland Hillary
Mason and directed by Nicholas roegg
critics say don't look now patiently
build suspense with haunting imagery and
a chilling score causing viewers to feel
Donald Sutherland and Julie Chrissy's
grief deep within
perfect
[Music]
and a friend
I won't hurt you
come on Darlings
[Music]
wait
[Music]
foreign
number four Nosferatu
Jonathan Harker is sent away to Count
Dracula's castle to sell him a house in
Verna where he lives but Count Dracula
is vampire an undead ghoul living off
men's blood inspired by a photograph of
Lucy Harker Jonathan's wife Dracula
moves to Verna bringing with him depth
and plague an unusually contemplative
version of Dracula in which the vampire
Bears a cross of not being able to get
old and die starring Klaus Kinski
Isabelle at Janny Bruno Gans and
directed by Werner Herzog critics say
stunning visuals from Verner Herzog and
an intense portrayal of the famed
bloodsucker from Klaus Kinski make this
remake of Nosferatu a horror classic in
its own right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number three Halloween
on a cold Halloween night in 1963
six-year-old Michael Myers brutally
murdered his 17 year old sister Judith
he was sentenced and locked away for 15
years but on October 30th 1978 while
being transferred for a court date a 21
year old Michael Myers steals a car and
escapes Smith's Grove he returns to his
quiet hometown of Haddonfield Illinois
where he looks for his next victims
starring Donald Pleasence Jamie Lee
Curtis Nancy keys and directed by John
Carpenter critics say scary suspenseful
and viscerally thrilling Halloween set
the standard for modern horror films
I'm scared there's nothing to be scared
of are you sure
how
killed him
he can't kill the boogeyman
get in there come on Tommy now lock the
door
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
number two jaws
when a young woman is killed by a shark
while skinny dipping near the New
England tourist town of Amity Island
police chief Martin Brody wants to close
the beaches but mayor Larry Vaughn
overrules him fearing that the loss of
tourist Revenue will [ __ ] the town
ichthyologist Matt Hooper and grizzled
Ship Captain Quint offered to help Brody
capture the killer Beast and the trio
engage in an epic battle of Man vs
nature starring Roy Schneider Robert
Shaw Richard Dreyfus and directed by
Steven Spielberg critics say compelling
well-crafted storytelling and a
judicious sense of Terror ensure Steven
Spielberg's jaws has remained a
benchmark in the art of delivering
modern Blockbuster thrills
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
deep red
a psychic medium is brutally murdered
and musician Marcus Daly feels a need to
solve the case since he was the one who
discovered the body working with him is
reporter Gianna brezzi who hopes for a
big scoop by solving the case when one
of Marcus's own friends ends up murdered
at the hands of the same killer the
resourceful pair realized they must work
fast to uncover the murderer's Identity
or they might serve as a maniac's next
victims starring David Hemmings Daria
nicolotti Gabriel Lavia and directed by
Dario Argento critics say the kinetic
camera work and brutal over-the-top Gore
that made Dario Argento famous is on
Full display but the addition of a
compelling complex story makes deep red
a masterpiece
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
and before we get to number one here is
another honorable mention Eraserhead
Henry resides alone in a bleak apartment
surrounded by industrial Gloom and when
he discovers that an earlier fling with
Mary ax left her pregnant he marries the
expectant mother and has her move in
with him things take a decidedly strange
turn when the couple's baby turns out to
be a bizarre lizard-like creature that
won't stop wailing I mean yeah that's
the serving other characters including a
disfigured lady who lives inside a
radiator inhabit the building and add to
Henry's troubles starring Jack Nance
Charlotte Stewart Alan Joseph Jean Bates
and directed by David Lynch critics say
David Lynch is surreal Eraserhead uses
detailed visuals and a creepy score to
create a bizarre and disturbing look
into a man's fear of Parenthood
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
your Vice is a locked room and only I
have the key
oliviero is a drunk burned out Rider who
amuses himself by hosting orgies and
humiliating his wife when a number of
women are murdered in grisly fashion
oliviero becomes a prime suspect
starring edwidge fennek Anita strinberg
Luigi pastille and directed by Sergio
Martino Jordan M Smith from
ionscinema.com says visually Sumptuous
narratively thrilling and musically
memorable Martino's take on Poe is in
absolutely delightful melodramatic
hybrid giallo
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and finally number one alien
in deep space the crew of the commercial
Starship Nostromo is awakened from their
cryosleep capsules halfway through their
journey home to investigate a distress
call from an alien vessel the terror
begins when the crew encounters a nest
of eggs inside the alien ship an
organism from inside an egg leaps out
and attaches itself to one of the crew
causing him to fall into a coma starring
Tom scarrett Sigourney Weaver John Hurt
and directed by Ridley Scott critics say
a modern classic alien Blends science
fiction horror and Bleak poetry into a
seamless hole
don't do
hey hey come on
come on baby
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love
until next time I am your host Naz Perez
and we will see you back here for more
top tens on the Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
foreign
[Music]